oublié l'anniversaire de ma soeur tu
peux parler moteur de mesmari coriace
que vous soyez le spectacle de clôture
des francos n'est ce pas symbolique le
pour clôturer le plus gros festival de
musique en français au québec
ouais oui c'est symbolique surtout dans
l'état du rap game en ce moment qui est
en train de se propulse maintenant
compétition avec la pop sauter sans
faire les charts et cela n'a pas eu de
témoin dans les dix combattants
la culture peut parfois être dur est ce
qu'il ya une saine compétition entre les
artistes de la scène par william et une
compétition saine dans une compétition
sont repartis de l'esprit du du rap vous
états unis ça toujours été comme ça sa
part de la gare is causeway sco c'est
parce que sa fille n'est que des morts
mais mais oui cette compétition lancée
dans l'esprit du bal aura pas entre eux
de garder goût de beaucoup de gens ainsi
qu'ils meurent parce qu'ils pensent que
le cepiv mans - jean-marc la maison bada
une pugnacité de choses pour moi un
motard des cimes départ ses filets
ci-dessus devront les odeurs qui lui a
peut-être que ça devient ça devient très
inspirant 40% monde rigole c'est comme
une audi connu pour le fait pas qui
souvent sexy aux excès à la taxe comme
un niveau habitent toutes sortes a
raison
avec raison ce domaine qui se prête à ça
pour quoi ah ben parce que c'est s'est
offert ces malheureuses et celles
promues ce qui s'étoffe la vie publique
c'est pas facile la vie publique la
caméra en face est une espèce d'animal
en cage et regarder tout le temps
particulièrement quand tu exploses un
peu trop ta vie privée comme j'ai fait
cette offre
c'est vraiment difficile chaque fois
être fou il faut être fait fort pour
passer à travers surtout pourquoi
prètres pensent que autant d'artistes
sont élevés
le film est ruinée servolex au moins 27
ans dont le rôle social qui je parle de
mes gosses start qui peuvent pas vivre
avec cette pression là qui font le bilan
enfin attention fait la nation mais
pippa du désert nos salutations et le 30
à 35 alors comment faites-vous pour
hiver acceptation c'est justement c'est
de tomber dans d'autres enfin moi je
suis quelqu'un qui a un tempérament
indépendant sphinx et j'essaie de le
faire dans des trucs sont positifs puis
un bon équilibre de vie une bonne
hygiène de vie c'est vraiment pas une
question sorti depuis par ce revirement
soudain événements spectacles ou de soie
mâle santé l'avait déjà dit que votre
plus grand regret ne pas avoir fini vos
études secondaires
ça doit encore puisque aujourd'hui vous
quand vous rencontrez vos fans vous aux
gens vous leur dites financer vos études
ne soient pas des rencontres dans les
écoles où je parle de mon parcours
depuis maintenant vous est ce parce que
vous les parents à vie au moins mais
c'est sa règle et ce n'est pas la
vingtaine vraiment difficile à cause des
retombées de ces joutes sans mépris de
ce temps beaucoup de son album eu un
gros succès aussi s'arrêter sur quatre
albums que j'ai commencé à vivre de ma
musique ses facultés plus difficile puis
une question d'exemple si mes enfants et
moi j'ai pas mon secondaire 5
je veux aller chercher juste pour vendre
ma fille j'ai mon diplôme selon
l'annoncé reach
zadi exemple c'est prêcher par l'exemple
que je veux faire
llanelli comme stalock drive unlimited
10h30 la première chanson sur votre
nouvel album ils parlent de leur séjour
en institut psychiatrique
qu'est ce qui sépare à j 3 m de ça c'est
non seulement du délai je pense que
n'importe qui doit mettre les jeunes ont
atteint entre temps en temps justement
ce qui s'est passé puis justement jean
parent ou jean pas mais sans en parler
le cheval un peu de ce que je devais
pendant ce temps le maire mais justement
c'est ça aussi c'est un message que j'ai
c'est d'envoyer aux jeunes s'est jamais
de mauvais moments c'est jamais mal de
demander de l'aide quand ça va pas être
beaucoup de garde tout pour tous les
goûts à damas une telle taxe et que les
gars y parle pas dans l'émotion puis
disent rien ils gardent pour un poids de
forme ont une façade sont maintenant
c'est pas vraiment donné il faut que tu
fous qui jette les images mentales si
j'ai besoin d'être sûr pas retenu après
c'est un peu ça c'est ce que j'ai fait
emmanuel dubois alias coriace merci
le score
[Musique]